de regreso a la lista de países que a
ojos de washington apoyan el terrorismo
cuba acaba de unirse de nuevo a siria
irán y corea del norte en el poco
prestigioso listado a tan sólo nueve
días del fin de la administración de
donald trump con esta medida de nuevo
hacemos responsable al gobierno de cuba
y mandamos un claro mensaje el régimen
castrista debe acabar con el apoyo al
terrorismo internacional y con la
subversión de la justicia estadounidense
barack obama había sacado a cuba de
dicha lista en el año 2015 que había
lanzado una nueva era en las relaciones
bilaterales entre otros enemigos desde
la guerra fría pero desde su llegada el
poder
trump fiel a la línea del partido
republicano y a la electoral de la
comunidad cubanoamericana de florida no
ha dejado dar marcha atrás puso fin a
los cruceros entre los dos países en
2019 en septiembre anunció nuevas
sanciones
vamos a restringir aún más las
importaciones de alcohol y tabaco de
cuba nada sorprendente resulta que el
presidente saliente quiere evitar al
máximo las posibilidades de un nuevo
acercamiento entre washington y la
habana antes de abandonar el cargo algo
que ha generado rabia entre los cubanos
principalmente la del canciller bruno
rodríguez condenamos la hipócrita y
cínica calificación de cuba como estado
patrocinador del terrorismo anunciada
por eeuu el oportunismo político de esta
nación es reconocido por todo el que
tenga una preocupación honesta ante el
flagelo del terrorismo y sus víctimas
queda por saber si joe biden estará
dispuesto a un nuevo giro de 180 grados
como lo invitó a hacer los homólogo
cubano miguel díaz canel el pasado 17 de
diciembre